hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich habe heute ein leckeres muffin
rezept für euch hab echt schon lange
keine muffins mal gemacht und zwar geht
es dir heute mit birnen mit haselnüssen
und später kommen dann noch eine leckere
karamellsoße obendrauf karamellsoße
finde ich sehr lecker und murat findet
ihr auch super lecker und marc parlament
total und auf den ersten blick sind es
ganz viele zutaten aber es sind schon
viele aber es sind auch viele
grundzutaten ich zeige euch jetzt mal
kurz ich hab hier 90 gramm butter die
habe ich bereits in einem kleinen topf
zerlassen zweier 250 milliliter
buttermilch etwas vanille extrakt und
salz ich habe ich zwei birnen 125 gramm
zucker 125 gramm mehl und 75 km/h
verfolgt ein bisschen jetzt gerne gehabt
locken dann habe ich hier 60 gramm
vollkornmehl und hier ein paar gewürze
auch als ich hab' ich zehnten halben
teelöffel die habe ich in viertel
teelöffel natron und drei viertel
teelöffel backpulver damit gut aufgeht
hier sind 125 gramm ganze haselnüsse und
hier habe ich noch etwas muskatnuss dann
kardamom kapseln und schoko trupps 100 g
so das war's und die zutaten für die
karamellsoße zeige ich euch später weil
der platz reiche nicht aus
also zuerst mal nehme ich jetzt die
haselnüsse und die muss ich ganz grob
hacken können wir jetzt mit einer
küchenmaschine machen aber da ich sie
wirklich nur ganz grob hacken will mache
ich es einfach ganz mit dem messer hier
und die möchte ich gleich damit sie ein
schönes aroma haben in der pfanne ohne
fett rösten
die hessen ist lässt sich jetzt in der
pfanne und passt einfach auf das sie
nicht verbrennen also ab und so immer
mal wieder schütteln und jetzt kann ich
schon mal meine zwei birnen schälen und
die werde ich dann mit der
küchenmaschine einfach kurz weinreich
die haselnüsse sind jetzt gerüstet da
habe ich jetzt die pfanne aus als ein
herd ausgeschaltet und das jetzt einfach
eine pfanne abkühlen
die bildung werde ich jetzt keinen
gleich fein raspeln und die karton
kapseln mal ich jetzt auch weil ihr
könnt die übrigens auch bereits gemahlen
kaufen aber ich habe immer ganz gern so
am stück und im ganzen und dann kann ich
sie eben fein mahlen
ich nehme dafür ist einfach die
gewürzmühle
jetzt ist alles vorbereitet jetzt kann
ich den teig endlich zu bereiten
ich gebe es die karten also den
gemeinden karte moment habe ich jetzt
hier in der schüssel und zwar 70 das
jetzt kurz durch weil ich dann noch so
ein bisschen was von der schale habe und
da gibt es einfach nur so viel mit dazu
wir möchten natürlich könnte dir noch
einfach weglassen gibt halt noch mal ein
tolles aroma und jetzt wirklich alle
trockenen zu tag hier in dieser
schlüssel gibt jetzt auch die muskatnuss
direkt mit rein und auch die schoko
trotz und dann einfach kurz mit einem
kochlöffel oder mit einem back löffel
durchführen
und jetzt in dieser großen schüssel
verrühren die flüssigen zutaten also die
die kann ich einmal ganz kurz einem
schneebesen durchrühren kann die
buttermilch dem ist auch das alles mit
dazu das war auch trockenzeiten ordne
trockenen dazu geben könnt und etwas
vanille extrakt dann auch gleich die
gute jetzt wirklich einfach nur noch
alle zutaten zusammen also jetzt hier
die trockenen zutaten mit rein und aber
auch die birne
jetzt habe ich hier meine muffin
backform bereits mit papier förmchen
ausgelegt und kann den teig jetzt mit
dem als portionierer portionierung
das ist auch wirklich eigentlichen ganz
schnelles rezept man muss halt nur ein
paar vorbereitungen treffen also gerade
mit der birne die bälle reifen die
haselnüsse hacken und die gewürze
zerkleinern aber ansonsten geht es
ziemlich schnell weil der teig einfach
kurz mit der hand berührt wird
und jetzt kann ich die gerösteten
haselnüssen doch auf die oberfläche
gelegen
bei mir sind es jetzt insgesamt 20
muffins und die werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 20 bis 25 minuten
gebacken und während der bauzeit kann
ich schon mal die karamellsoße
herstellen und richtet auch gleich die
zutaten
für die karamellsoße braucht ihr 50
milliliter wasser 100 gramm zucker 150
milliliter sahne zehn gramm butter eine
prise salz und etwas von elektra qt das
wasser gebe ich jetzt mit zum mit dem
zucker zusammen in einen kleinen topf
und so besteht einfach nicht die gefahr
dass der zucker jetzt gleich zu schnell
karamellisiert und dann verbrennt denn
ansonsten könnten wir auch den zucker
ohne wasser karamellisieren lassen
aber ich lasse jetzt kurz zusammen
aufkochen und anderen anfängt so richtig
schön zu schmelzen das heißt also bald
karamellisiert und eine hellbraune farbe
hat gebe ich dann die anderen zutaten
betreiben
beim karamell müsste jetzt ganztag
aufpassen das wird nämlich ziemlich
schnell dunkel
das heißt sobald ist hell karamell
farben ist können wir gleich vom herd
unternehmen zu dunkel das nicht werden
weil es ansonsten zeit bitter wird dann
schmeckt euch die karamellsoße nicht
also immer gut aufpassen
das riecht und ich nehme sie jetzt
gleich runter jetzt gebe ich die sahne
mit rein damit ist nicht wirklich
aufpassen dass nicht spritzt denn das
ist wirklich sehr heiß
bei mir kocht jetzt die karamellsoße
schon seit etwa 5 minuten bei mir war
eben das problem ich hatte die sahne aus
dem kühlschrank genommen die war viel zu
kalt und als ich die mitte der topf
gegeben habe was und großer klumpen aber
das löst sicher wieder auf weil es ist
ja karamell und jetzt gebe ich hier noch
eine prise salz mit rein dann noch etwas
vanille extrakt so ein bisschen für das
aroma wobei es jetzt schon wirklich
richtig lecker schmeckt und noch ein
stück butter
sobald sich die gute aufgelöst das kann
ich die soße so ein bisschen zum
abkühlen auf die seite stellen
jetzt sieht man auch ganz gut jetzt ist
die soße noch richtig flüssig und wenn
sie jetzt etwas abkühlt wirst du dann
auch etwas fester also etwas dicker die
machen sind abgekühlt und auch die
karamellsoße sitzt abgekühlt und ich
finde es auch richtig schön von der
konsistenz richtig gut dick geworden und
jetzt kann ich die muffins anrichten und
murat darf gleich probieren so richtig
cool aus ich ja eben schon die soße
probiert jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
soße darüber geben wie es hier ist gut
sind hatte ich ja mal liegt ist nicht
wieder anmeldungen sind ob es das sieht
richtig toll dass es so schön dass man
diese großen hasen stückchen noch drauf
hat und er rastet weniger nicht
aufgemacht habe jetzt macht
also ich finde diese karamellsoße die
könnte zum beispiel auch für ein eis
benutzen oder für was anderes also die
eigentlich da echt super dafür
und die könnte auch im kühlschrank
aufheben ich musste richtig falsch
gemacht dass der vollkornmehl oder
haferflocken und die ganzen gewürze wie
verstehen was ganz anderes
also ich finde auch dass ich einfach mal
so ein rezepten muffin den mal auch
nicht jeden tag hatte ich finde es etwas
ganz besonderes mit den haselnüssen mit
den gerösteten mit den verschiedenen
gewürzen mit den birnen und daneben noch
mit dieser leckeren karamellsoße wenn
jetzt natürlich die karten kapsel nicht
habt oder nicht möchtet könnt ihr
natürlich weglassen
die bühne könnte durch den apfel
austauschen die haselnüsse könnte
ersetzen also ihr könnt auch gerne alles
wieder ersetzen und austauschen
das ist jetzt nur eine anregung von mir
was genau passiert ja genau
und dann könnt ihr gerne wenn dieses
rezept nach machen wollt alles nachlesen
auf sally blog.de und mir dann auch ein
foto auf facebook oder instagram
schicken
bis zum nächsten mal ich mache jetzt die
anderen fertig